millions of buffalo once roamed the
american west providing sustenance for
native american tribes until the giant
creatures were hunted to near extinction
by european settlers now those same
tribes are leading the effort to bring
the buffalo back
buffalo are an elusive breed here on the
eastern border of glacier national park
they're taking off they're taking off
yeah they they won't wait for us these
ones but ervin carlson and the blackfeet
nation are changing that
increasing their numbers where only two
herds of a few hundred remain but the
buffalo that we're talking about
you know you can link to your people the
good part about it is that
they originated from here specifically
right in this area and were part of us
and we were part of them partnering with
the wildlife conservation society in
several tribes they returned 90 buffalo
to blackfeet territory reinforcing a
kinship passed through the ages they
were our food our clothing our lodging
our tools they were our whole economy
you know that's what we
existed on them
when the european settlers arrived in
the 1800s the delicate balance started
to shift to get rid of the buffalo was
to
actually get rid of the indians too you
know that's that was our existence so
that was the real kind of the downward
trend
in the 19th century there were millions
of buffalo that roamed this region
until they were hunted to near
extinction
they may have died out if not for a
novel idea in 1907
to preserve the remaining few the
blackfeet captured those calves and they
took them across the mountains and they
sold them to the canadian government and
that's how they got into canada and they
eventually ended up at the elk island
national park those descendants survived
there for more than 100 years
then in 2016 parks canada gave the
buffalo initiative permission to return
100 buffalo to the blackfeet reservation
when we got back waiting for us and all
in celebration of these buffalo coming
home
blessing ceremonies were held along the
400 mile route one day later the buffalo
were released on the montana plains that
was a real great day for us they've been
living here peacefully ever since
but 13 of them made a detour continuing
on to california's oakland zoo we were
able to secure some of these to bring
them here to oakland for an incredible
not only exhibit but really the
educational purpose of why they're here
zoo ceo nick dehazia plans to return the
10 babies born and bred here to the
montana plains there is the red dog that
was just born 24 hours ago watching this
young one yesterday literally within
hours of birth just trying to stand up
and walk and you can see that right now
getting her footing the goal is to
increase this herd's size and even its
territory they'll begin by opening the
boundary between glacier national park
and the reservation so they'll have free
rain to roam the mountain range this is
going to take a long time but that's
what we fight for every day a homecoming
for 100 descendants of the original
plains buffalo is just a fraction of the
millions that once lived there
but for the blackfeet it's a bold and
bodacious start to restore the true
american west what does an animal
roaming in the 21st century have to do
with how you live today
to me it keeps
it keeps our history
and our culture alive this is home to
them
where they originated from and were
traveled a big full circle to across the
mountains to canada
to back here to home so it only took 100
something years only took 100 and some
years
but it happened and it's symbolic but it
means something to these people
we love buffalo i love buffalo i love
buffalo and buffalo just for the record
just for the record they are bison here
in america they're known as buffalo in
africa but for some reason we love that
term so i just because of buffalo by the
way no matter what you call them they
are so majestic they just are